(H: *übertrieben* Woow, was ist das denn für eine Winkelpalette?!)
Das hier? Das ist unsere Winkelpalette!
(H: Das hab' ich noch nie gesehen!)
Hi zusammen und willkommen zu diesem sehr besonderen Video!
Ihr seht immer wieder meine Utensilien wie z.B. diese Spezial Winkelpalette von mir,
die normale Palette, das Tortenringmesser, Backformlöser und, und, und!
Die Produkte, die lassen wir alle mit ganz viel Liebe und ganz vielen Gedankengängen produzieren!
Das ist nicht ein Produkt, was einfach da ist.
Wir setzen uns hin, wir machen uns Gedanken, wir entwickeln neue Produkte
und das alles hier in Deutschland, in NRW!
Jetzt haben Hamza und ich uns gedacht: Ganz ehrlich?
Da müssen wir doch mal hinter die Kulissen gehen und euch einfach zeigen:
Wie sind so diesen ganzen Prozesse? Wie entsteht überhaupt ein Produkt?
Und das Coole ist, dass wir dafür genau jetzt nach Solingen fahren!
So, meine Lieben! Wir sind jetzt angekommen in Solingen bei der Firma triangle
und hier werden echt 1/3 der Kiki Produkte hergestellt!
Und wir gehen jetzt einfach mal gemeinsam durch die heiligen Produktionshallen.
*Klingel*
Hi Kiki!
(K: Hi Marko!)
Alles gut?
(K: Ja und selbst?)
Ja, Danke! Komm rein!
(K: Lässt du uns rein? Super!)
Komm rein!
(M: Martin, kommst du mal? Die Kiki ist da!)
Herzlich willkommen bei triangle!
(K: Dankeschön Martin!)
(K: Magst du uns vielleicht die Produktion zeigen?)
Gerne!
Hier sind wir in unserer Stanzerei, die vorzugsweise aus Exzenterpressen besteht,
an denen gestanzt und umgeformt wird.
Da ist gerade auch ein Produkt, was für euch ist, auf der Maschine.
(K: Ja, Tortenringmesser!)
Da werden hier und auch da Teile bearbeitet,
die sich hier an dem Tortenringmesser wieder finden.
Einmal die Klinge und einmal die Haltespange.
(K: M-hm!)
(K: Also Martin was passiert hier genau und was macht der Dominik da vorne eigentlich?)
Hier werden die Teile für die Tortenringmesser vom Coil, der Haspel, abgehaspelt
und dort beim Dominik geschnitten.
Also das, was sich hier im Griff verbirgt, komplett als Metallteil
wird hier gerade vom Endlosband auf Länge gebracht.
Und so sieht die Klinge dann fertig aus,
die dann hinterher hier so im Griff eingebettet ist.
(K: Perfekt!)
Hier wird gerade die Halteklammer für das Tortenringmesser bearbeitet.
Die sieht als Rohling erstmal gerade aus
und was da gerade gemacht wird ist das Umbiegen, der erste Arbeitsgang für das Spitzenformen.
So sieht der Rohling aus
und die Daniela biegt gerade die vordere Spitze an dem Teil,
die dann vorne so abgewinkelt ist damit sie über den Tortenring passt.
Und die Klammer dient dann dazu, dass ihr nicht abrutscht beim Lösen eurer Kreation
und dass dann eben nichts kaputt geht!
So, hier kommen wir in unsere Handschleiferei  - was ganz traditionell ist für Solingen -
wo händisch Dinge, Oberflächen bearbeitet, geschärft oder geschliffen, entgratet werden.
(K: Also alles noch Handarbeit!)
Da kommt gerade der Torsten, der sich hier sehr gut auskennt.
Der wird den Rest dann dir erklären und begleiten.
(K: Okay, super! Zeigst du uns dann den nächsten Schritt?)
Das werde ich gerne machen!
Wir sind jetzt hier an dem Arbeitsplatz vom Vladimir.
Der entgratet vorne die Spitze von den eben gestanzten Tortenmessern.
(K: Ist das sonst zu scharf oder-?)
Genau, sonst ist das zu scharfkantig.
Wir sind jetzt hier an dem Arbeitsplatz von dem Volker.
Hier werden von den Paletten, von den gestanzten Paletten, die Kanten ringsum bearbeitet.
(K: So, und was passiert hier jetzt noch genau?)
Hier sind wir jetzt an der Endbearbeitung von der Oberfläche der Palette.
Das ist die, die der Volker eben die Kanten geschliffen hat
und der Christos bringt jetzt quasi diesen Schliff auf die Palette auf.
(K: Ah, und dann ist die quasi mattiert und sieht auch super aus!)
Genau!
(K: Also ich hab' ja bei mir im Sortiment auch viel Mattiertes
weil ich's einfach schicker finde, man sieht die Fingerabdrücke nicht drauf..
Und meinst du, ich darf mich mal an der Maschine versuchen?)
Auf jeden Fall, gar kein Problem!
(K: Okay, super!)
(K: Perfektes Ergebnis würde ich mal sagen!)
(H: Boah, Hammer!)
(K: Was sagst du? Erste Mal!)
Ich glaube, ich kann einpacken!
(K: Ja, ich übernehme deinen Platz!)
(H: *lacht*)
(K: Du kannst nach hause, Feierabend machen!)
(K: Also Martin, das ist unsere beliebteste Palette! Da saßen wir auch zusammen am Tisch und haben überlegt:
"Wie soll der Winkel sein? Wie soll die Spitze sein?" Wie wird das jetzt hergestellt?
Ist das das gleiche Prinzip?)
Ähnlich wie das andere, was wir vorhin gesehen haben, auch.
Es wird ein Streifen benutzt, der jetzt da liegt.
Das ist nicht vom Coil abzuhaspeln
und wird durch ein Werkzeug geführt, was der Dominik jetzt da gerade bedient.
Da sieht das erst am Streifen so aus.
(K: So, jetzt kommt ja das Wichtigste: der Winkel!)
M-hm, das ist ähnlich wie bei dem anderen Produkt auch, dass Teile einzeln eingelegt werden.
So sieht der Rohling aus, gerade wie er grad gestanzt worden ist
und in 2 Operationen werden dann diese Winkel hergestellt.
So und der Bernd montiert jetzt hier die Griffe für die XXL-Paletten!
Jetzt habt ihr die wichtigsten Abläufe gesehen und ich find's so heftig, wie viel Handarbeit dahinter steckt!
Jetzt fehlt mir noch ein Schritt: die Verpackung!
Um das Packaging haben wir uns richtig viele Gedanken gemacht.
Und da ist die Miriam! Wir gehen mal zu ihr und dann soll sie uns das am besten mal zeigen!
(K: Darf ich euch zwei mal ganz kurz stören?)
Hallo Kiki!
(K: Hallo!)
(K: So, wir zwei haben uns ja auf der Messe kennengelernt, auf der Ambiente.)
(K: Du machst Marketing aber auch Verpackung.)
Genau!
(K: Da bin ich ja bei dir genau richtig! Kannst du uns unsere Kiki-Verpackungen zeigen?)
Klar!
Ja, hier haben wir deine neuen Wellenschneider-Verpackungen!
Die sind gerade druckfrisch gekommen diese Woche!
(K: Sehr schön! Wo werden die gedruckt?)
Die machen wir auch hier in Solingen.
(K: In Solingen!)
Und hier haben wir die Backformlöser-Verpackungen!
(K: Sehr schön!)
(K: Und hier sitzt jemand und verpackt das per Hand?)
Genau, die werden alle per Hand verpackt!
(K: Ok! Ich glaub, ich mach' mich mal ran. Ich verpack' jetzt auch ein bisschen!)
Ja, mach das!
(K: Super!)
(K: Miriam, was sagst du?)
*Grillenzirpen*
*beide lachen*
(K: Ich darf hier schon mal nicht anfangen!)
Nein, ich wär - du hast das hier oben mit eingeklappt und jetzt - *lacht*
(H: Kiki, bleib du mal lieber in der Küche, ne? Schön backen und kochen!)
(K: Jaja!)
(K: Naja, schön ehrlich bist du wenigstens!)
Okay! *lacht*
(K: So Miriam, was sagst du?)
Ich würd' sagen du kannst bei uns anfangen!
(K: Super! Ihr könnt alle nach hause gehen, ich mach' weiter!)
(K: Hallo Christine!)
Hallo Kiki!
(K: Lässt du mich kurz rein?)
Ja natürlich!
(K: Ja super!)
Komm!
(K: Also Christine du bist ja jetzt eine Frau an der Spitze sage ich mal,
das finde ich ja auch immer sehr schön zu sehen!)
(K: Was ich cool fand als wir hierher kamen - vor ca. 2 Jahren war das glaube ich?)
(K: Da haben wir eine ganz geringe Abnahmemenge abgekauft bei euch.)
(K: Da waren wir noch ganz am Anfang, der Shop war in Planung)
und das war gar nicht so profitabel für euch aber du hast da schon an uns geglaubt!)
Ja, auf jeden Fall! Wir haben uns getroffen und wir hatten ein wirklich nettes Meeting!
Wir haben uns über dies und das unterhalten, über Kochen unterhalten, übers Backen unterhalten..
darüber, was du kochst und was ich koche und das passte! Das war einfach super sympathisch und es hat auch Spaß gemacht.
Und wir sind ja auch nicht ein Unternehmen, das direkt überlegt: " Was kann ich jetzt da raus schlagen?"
sondern das Ganze muss Spaß machen, es muss Ideen geben.
Du hast einen sehr innovativen Eindruck gemacht, hattest direkt ein paar Ideen, was man denn machen könnte
und das macht uns natürlich auch Spaß!
(K: Ja, sehr schön! Und jetzt siehe da:
1/3 unserer Ware kommt von euch tatsächlich!)
(K: Und wir haben auch neue Produkte zusammen entwickelt. Und das finde ich eben so schön:
Ihr seid nahbar, ihr seid um die Ecke. Wir fahren runter, wir bequatschen uns
und deshalb bin ich einfach so dankbar auch über die Zusammenarbeit!)
Ja, die Zusammenarbeit macht wirklich Spaß! Also wir haben kurze Wege,
wir haben dann hier Rückfragen gehabt, mussten uns da nochmal abstimmen, konnten uns telefonisch kurzschließen..
Das war nie irgendwie ein Problem, den einen oder den anderen zu erreichen.
Das hat ganz gut funktioniert und wir haben das ja relativ schnell umsetzen können.
(K: Genau!)
(K: Und ich danke dir für deine Zeit. Danke, dass wir uns die Produktionshallen angucken durften, das ist ja auch nicht selbstverständlich!)
(K: Und ich hoffe, dass wir uns dann sehr schnell wieder sehen!)
Danke, dass ihr gekommen seid. Es hat Spaß gemacht!
Okay, schön war's!
(K: Ja, fand ich auch!)
(K: Mach's gut Christine, man sieht sich!)
Mach's gut!
(K: Ciao!)
Bis bald, ciao!